congrats to Janae Iko and Big Sean the
pair just welcomed their first child
together
[Music]
is also Mom to 13 year old namiko her
daughter would see her Orion the brother
of b2k's Omarion vacations
Janae and Sean announced they were
expecting in July after Paparazzi picked
surface showing the songstress sporting
what looked to be a baby bum Sean kept
the confirmation simple writing on
Instagram can't wait to be a dad I'm way
up I feel Bliss Janae also hit up the
gram to subtly address the happy news
posting this throwback pic of baby Janae
holding an imaginary bump not long after
a rep for the Stars told E.T they were
overjoyed and look forward to this next
chapter
[Music]
Sean and Janae started out as
collaborators and continue to make music
together to this day the rapper recently
surprised the crowd at Lollapalooza by
bringing his lady out on stage he kissed
her belly during their performance and
concert goers went wild
who first started dating in 2016 and
actually broke up for a bit in 2019
getting back together sometime in 2020.
[Music]
fast forward to the 2021 Grammys and the
power couple reflected on the power of
their music with E.T I think we all put
a lot into our music and it always feels
good to be recognized in any capacity
you know and that's what it's all about
for me I'm just thankful to be here and
what do you have to say it's been a
blessing to be here we lost a lot of
people we continue to lose a lot of
people so a lot of Heroes a lot of
people that are so talented so you know
we wake up and get to be here so it's an
honor
[Music]